hello rejects we're gonna watch the
trailer today for fifty shades darker
who is not excited for this film I bet
everyone's really enthusiastic about
this picture the first one was so good
so rewarding it lived up to expectations
of fans and it also brought in a whole
new generation of audiences
I'm sure there's the ones gonna do the
same oh there's some cool song in this
trailer you know what I'm gonna try to
be positive about this one I want you
back
I'm not very good at this I never wanted
to try again
don't dinner with me okay fine dinner
dumbass
hungry but we are only talking and that
is it oh no you idiot
take him off what oh oh that's hot
oh that's pretty hot
[Music]
oh oh yeah clever dog you boyfriend has
a reputation do you think you're the
first woman who tried to save him
you were he's changing that what he
wants anymore but it's what he needs
[Music]
[Music]
sex stuff looks great
what was that god I want to do it to
this song
all right okay there's something were to
happen to you I could never forgive
myself in a day and age we're great
trailers I mean out of bad movies I'm
still skeptical but I will say that was
a good trailer I thought it was a good
trailer I really don't know what the
response is on this trailer what a lot
of people are saying to me it doesn't
look that much different than the first
trailer they released I mean except for
a few more sexy moments like when he's
like take off take it off and she starts
taking off from under worth it oh that's
kinky not some kinky [ __ ] and then the
elevator there's a lot of PDA in here a
lot of PDA a lot of inappropriate public
displays of affection but who knows
maybe we'll have a sexy where a bunch of
people are just watching them that would
be something else huh I mean they're
both very attractive people like the
dudes sexy [ __ ] Dakota Johnson sexy I
think they're both very sexy people and
the sex stuff looks like it could be
amped up I mean one thing that people
felt was lacking was the sex stuff in
the first one so I feel like they could
be amping it up same time though this
looks different in some ways like this
looks more like a thriller a more of an
interesting thriller than the first one
I got to give it that do I think this
film's gonna be great
definitely not do I have skepticism most
certainly with that being said I feel
like they're at least trying to make it
better for what I see from the trailer
sometimes you're just wrong though when
you watch the movie trailers gonna be
very misleading so like I say that was
kind of a hot trailer man I thought that
was kind of a hot trick
I mean Anastasia's back she's still
stupid falling in love with this guy I
mean some people probably think I'm
being judgmental by saying that I don't
know that kind of goes against the whole
arc of the first one where she left
Christian and actually ain't pulled back
in but then again you know I met women
who have dated guys who they shouldn't
have been dating and then they go back
to them and they still want to change
them but only someone can change
themselves you can't change
anyone to me this could be a good
representation of like toxic
relationships where a lot of times
sexual act attraction outweighs any of
the emotional and potential physical
pain that can occur from this I should
redo that take it I didn't say occur
properly but I'm not gonna do that and
maybe when I say thriller aspect you got
Kim Basinger in there who I'm assuming
is playing like a former lover of is I
know in the first one they hinted that
he had a Dom or something I forget the
technical terms on these things that he
had you know an older woman who who you
know sleeping with on love with and I'm
assuming that's probably her which is
cool cuz Kim Basinger is that sexy older
woman saw her at macelli's a couple
months ago didn't approach her but man
does she look fine I know what it's like
to be a guy who's jealous of a girl's
past and like the guy she's been with or
you know if she's dated more people or
slept with more people than I have which
is like 99.9 percent of the time I guess
I kind of like how they're dealing with
that in terms of you know it's a set of
the you know Christian Grey being
jealous of Anastasia its Anastasia has
to deal with the envy of all the people
from like it sounds like she's dealing
with a lot of people from Christian
Grey's past which I guess could be more
interesting because I don't think just
the two of them focusing primarily just
on them throughout the whole film I mean
they're gonna do that for this one it's
gonna primarily be them but I feel like
we're getting a much bigger cast this
time around which would make for a more
intriguing film hopefully I hope the
cover of crazy right now is used in this
movie and during one of their sex scenes
because it means just yeah I do not want
to do it to that song how do you just
not want to make love passionately to
that song it's like a great mix of
making love and rough at the same time
that's the best kind of sex where you're
connected but it's also intense you know
what I mean talking as an adult here
about sex I'm not talking some pervy
attitude saying the best kind of
lovemaking is when it's passionate hot
heated and I feel like it could deliver
on that the only thing that this film
really means to back this up is great
character like I hope they improve the
character of the performances get better
I hope this everything just gets better
otherwise you're just like I'd rather
just watch porn I feel like it's a lot
of people's thing when they when they
watch this it's like if
if you're not really into the story or
the characters and then the only times
where it's kind of enjoyable is when
their sex going on you're like this is
softcore porn not even that really
revealing kind of pornography I like
erotic thrillers you know I think of
like the good old Michael Douglas days
you know like Ant Man like disclosure or
fatal attraction like you know when
Michael Douglas was like boning women in
the 80s or 90s Cameron with the
Arrowwood let's see what some comments
are saying I got this one from the
movieclipstrailers
site yeah is sham 2044 watching a porno
is cheaper and saves one hour 30 minutes
of your time
oh yeah that was the movie I was like
what's going on like that helicopter was
firing bullets and they look like a
moment out of Kong Skull Island for a
second because I'm fifty Shades of
[ __ ] up I remember that line this
movie I feel I can succeed in two ways
one it just makes a better dramatic
thriller a better erotic thriller yeah
hey or B it just embraces that it's [ __ ]
and it goes with that like it goes to
the fact that it's cheesy and no silly
and ridiculous
if it can embrace that is the a lot of
the first one felt unintentionally bad
if this one goes the route of just
making a better movie or just going
intentionally bad I feel like you're
great it's not good when you try to make
a good movie then it ends up being [ __ ]
you gotta just know what you're trying
to make anyway guys what do you think of
a trailer did you get hot and bothered
are you annoyed again if you're new to
this channel subscribe today become a
reject damn that's not the catchphrase 1
million subscribers